i i place him as one of the premier
theoretical physicists
probably of all time is he's up there
he's with gail mann he's with feynman
he's with hawking
he's incredible um i think there's a
whole generation of us uh physicists
working today for whom
weinberg is is just well you know just
just a legend just just the the absolute
legend i know of um
a few guys i know who talked about you
know whenever whenever
they would literally bow to weinberg if
they heard him speak right so this is
this is a guy
who isn't just a noble or it he's a
noble laureate
absolute legend of physics he was the
one we looked up to his work which led
to the standard model of particle
physics has stood the test of time
one of the problems we have at the large
adron collider is we can't see
deviations from what he predicted
it's just so so superb and and so robust
in terms of impact of what he's achieved
in terms of you know impact on advancing
physics but also
his textbooks and and those sorts of
things that have taught us all
how to understand physics i mean any
physics i actually would claim to
understand
and that might be quite limited i would
say i'll be thanks to weinberg and and
actually following his message and and
what he taught us about physics absolute
legend he wrote a paper called a model
of the leptons you know leptons are
particles like the electron
it's a two and a half page paper
and he in it he he unified
the force of electromagnetism and the
weak force
we think of four forces of nature really
right we think of gravity we think of
the strong force which binds the nucleus
together we know the weak force which
you know why the sun burns why we're
alive and we know of electromagnetism
and one of the goals of theoretical
physics and actually weinberg was the
premier person in pushing for this goal
this reductionist idea was
maybe these four forces as you go to
higher and higher energies can be
described by a more unified approach
maybe there's an underlying mathematical
description which gives you all of them
and they only begin to manifest
themselves as the universe cools down
and expands
and we know of an example right
electromagnetism we know that we have
electricity and we have magnetism we
know that if we push a bar magnet
through a coil of wire it will produce a
current
so the magnetic field is affecting the
electric field we know that if we change
the electric field we'll produce a
magnetic field and maxwell showed
actually that we could think of them as
the same effectively
and what weinberg did in this amazing
paper are then
independently was done by salam and by
glacial was he demonstrated that you
could unify the weak force the weak
interactions with electromagnetism now
people have been trying to do this this
previously and in particular you know
people like sheldon glashoff who was
actually he was actually a high school
uh friend of of weinberg they went to
the same school they both won nobel
prizes and they went to the same school
how much is that and they won in the
same year as well okay glashow would
realize that you know if you if you want
to you've got electromagnetism you've
got the weak force the electro
electromagnetism contained the photon
the weak force believed to contain these
w bosons
uh one which was positively charged one
which was negatively charged
he wanted to bring them all together and
he realized that that just didn't seem
to balance there needed to be another
neutral sort of
something like the photon but another
one something else which is the z boson
which was associated with the weak force
so there were these things there were
these all these force carriers these
four force carriers and they had to be
put together in a consistent theory now
why did people believe they should be
put together was was because
you know
electromagnetism and weak force they
seem to be dancing in the same bottle
room in some respects you have you have
sort of for example the electromagnetic
force which is moving charges around and
the weak force which is somehow changing
electro electric charges you can have
processes that involve the weak force
where the electric charge changes
changes so it seemed like they were all
dancing in the same ballroom and it sort
of
it was natural to try to bring it
together glacial said well this is
probably what you need you probably need
this photon going along with these two w
bosons which are charged and but there
should also be this this zed boson which
should be neutral
but he couldn't quite figure out how to
put it all together in a consistent way
what wimbegg did was he took those
papers from 1964 that uh people had been
using to you know we now talk about with
the higgs mechanism and all the you know
the discovery of the higgs weinberg took
those papers and took the mechanism they
had for
for giving mass to some of these these
these bosons
and he incorporated it into this the
ideas of glacier and and people like
that in terms of bringing these two
forces together and he created this
consistent theory and what i
particularly like about it was that he
wasn't actually thinking about this
initially he was thinking about the
quarks he was thinking about the strong
force
and in his calculations he was finding
that it was predicting a massless
particle which was the pa the pion was
massless
but he knew the pion wasn't massless so
it wasn't working there
and at that time of his life he was he
had young children he was out looking
after them quite often because his wife
was working as well
and when he was out he was thinking
about what's going on and you realized
actually maybe i could apply this
formalism to the weak interactions and
and electromagnetism because we know the
photon is massless he had these four
sort of force carriers the photon and
the three carriers of the weak force he
needed to make three of them heavy and
so he realizes that meant that the higgs
particle that he had to introduce into
the game to make them heavy had to have
basically had to be able to give three
degrees of freedom to the three heavy
bosons
and then there would be one degree of
freedom left over which would be the
higgs that we see and it's exactly the
physics that we see
so this new theory which was unifying
the the weak interactions and the
electromagnetism predicted the existence
of what we call weak neutral currents or
the zed particle it's called which was
it was the initiator of an interaction
between if you had an electron and a
neutrino and this scatter so incomes and
electron incomes and neutrino and the
scatter
the the mediator
which allows for that scattering was
that it was this neutral current which
included the zed particle
and it was a prediction in this two and
a half page paper beautiful beautiful
paper
and
he didn't really believe
it he knew it was good
but he didn't really believe that it was
he didn't really think it's going to be
a description of nature
and this is really interesting because
he didn't know at that time whether this
theory which we call the electroweak
theory was what we call renormalizable
what does that mean renormalizable means
that you can take all the infinities
which often occur in quantum mechanics
in quantum field theory and properly
absorb them into physical quantities so
that you end up with a predictive theory
if you have something that gives you an
infinity and you don't know what to do
with it then how do you know how to
believe any of the finite results
renormalization is the technique which
allows you to properly absorb them
that's called the regularization bit and
then make a prediction for a finite
quantity he didn't know if the theory
was renormalizable
and it wasn't and so this this model got
very little attention if i remember
right it only had for about the first
two or three years three or four
citations it now has over eleven and a
half thousand by the way three or four
citations then in 1971
tooft and veltman
showed in their own nobel prize winning
work that this was a renormalizable
theory you could absorb these infinities
and wow took off
a year later
they found that the at cern they found
the existence of these neutral currents
during the first experiment 500 000
photographs were taken and the z
particle emerged
and that's what was measured inside this
chamber back in 1973.
so this is a big this is this is a piece
of history it really is a piece of
history this this the experiment that
went on in this machine
actually won uh glashoff
weinberg and salam the nobel prize in
1979 what happened in this they've got a
lot to thank thank this machine for yeah
i mean i think the way i've seen this
put really nicely in the last few days
you know sort of and i think it's nice
to put it in this context you know
isaac newton sort of
he sort of brought together sort of
terrestrial gravity and celestial
gravity you know he brought those two
together and merged them into one
maxwell you know he brought together
electricity and magnetism made them into
into into one unified theory and
weinberg did the same thing he took
electromagnetism in the weak theory and
he combined them into one theory which
was electroweak theory that was
weinberg's legacy to to bring these two
theories together and you just look at
the other names i mentioned and you
really see the context of the quality
we're talking about he also in in that
paper by the way the one that
the two and a half page paper he kind of
introduced the higgs
higgs of course had done his work in
1966 what what a time this was in the
early 64 65 66 so there was higgs there
was brought an angler and there was
kibble and collaborators and they'd all
postulated this particle which became
known as the higgs but what weinberg
actually did was weinberg actually
placed it in the context of the electro
weak theory he said it must be here and
when it is here it will give me these
interactions and so in some sense the
discovery of the higgs that this at the
lhc i think you could say his discovery
of the weinberg
higgs that he postulated would be there
i i would say weinberg what do you have
this uncanny knack of sort of unpicking
the the details of any any given
scenario in physics you know whether
you're talking about cosmology whether
you're talking about general relativity
whether you're talking about quantum
mechanics whether you're talking about
quantum field theory
whatever any branch of physics weinberg
had this ability just to
basically almost forget what everybody
else had told him about it
and look at it on his terms so we'd look
at this branch of physics let's say
quantum mechanics for the sake of
argument he'd look at it on his terms
and then unpick it
in his way
the coupling constant appears in the
lagrangian multiplying some kind of
operator and then somehow because of his
superb insight obviously
he was able to sort of
then understand it more deeply than
perhaps
others had and at the same time he was
able to convey that understanding to the
rest of us you know as much as we could
understand you know sort of the level of
weinberg things but but it you know i
think that's what it was i think was his
ability just to to stand back and say
i'm going to look at this on my terms
and then when he did that
you know things just opened up for him
you said you sort of talk about how this
famous paper was two and a half pages
and this little smile comes across your
face
why is that what's special about the
fact it was two and a half pages i think
it shows
this was someone who was so in charge of
what he was doing
that he knew the essence of what you
needed to say he knew exactly what
needed to be said and he knew exactly
how to say it and the eloquence of it is
like reading a beautiful novel i mean
when in heinz i think if i was reading
in the early 60s i was 67 i'd have been
totally flummoxed by it
but in hindsight having you know you you
teach courses on it you attend courses
on it you go to lectures on this subject
you become familiar with the terminology
and what it is to see it written as the
initial kind of breakthrough paper is
just staggering and i think that's why
smiling at the two and a half page and
the fact you know i'm currently writing
a 40-page paper and i think well what
what what impact is that going to have
on the world
you know you you go through his book on
quantum field theory and and or you know
or general relativity and things are
just put in in such a
in a clear way and and i said i i think
he is i think he's taught a generation
and how to think like a physicist i
think i think that's what it is he's
taught us how to how to think like a
physicist now i'm certain that many many
of us fall short we don't we're nowhere
near weinberg's level but but what we do
right i think we do right most was
thanks to the wayne weinberg has taught
us to think i think he really has taught
a generation of physicists how to think
properly so i started my phd in 1982 in
newcastle and for the first few months
anyone doing a phd knows yes you're
scrabbling in the dark you you might be
given a project to do and i did it and
i'd written a paper and
and that was great i had a lovely start
and but it wasn't what i wanted to
really do i didn't know what i really
wanted to do
and then i went to this meeting at the
royal society which weinberg had
organized and it was a meeting on the
fundamental constants it's i think it's
turned into quite a famous meeting
because i was no not because i was there
but um but he was there he was there
hawking was there it is the meeting
where and i was at the talk where
hawking said that n equals eight super
gravity is probably going to be the
theory of everything we've just got a
few things to wrap up and by the turn of
the century we'll have done it and
we're still searching for it
but weinberg came on and gave a talk
and i just sat there and i thought wow
wow
wow
and he was talking about some work he
did with another brilliant physicist or
mathematician really my mathematical
office is called philip candelas who's
raous professor at mathematics at oxford
they'd work together on a theory called
klutzy klein theory that is the idea
that the universe is made up of extra
dimensions and why don't we see them
well all the extra dimensions are in a
small in a sphere
and what he what they said was that the
forces that we see electromagnetism the
strong force and the weak force are
manifestations of this
compact dimensions
and i thought this was so beautiful
because you could have a theory here
which was this extra dimensional theory
which is pure gravity
but when you sort of take out your four
dimensions of space time that we live in
and you reinterpret these extra
dimensions you reinterpret them as the
forces of nature and and and i thought i
want to do this this is what i want to
do i was lucky because a a a guy came to
newcastle at the time called the
david tomes and he was working in this
field
and so we got working together and that
was my whole phd and then
at the end of my phd so my phd is on
quantum
collusion quantum corrections includes a
clan cosmologist because of a talk by
weimar yeah completely completely
because of this talk
weinberg didn't write any more papers on
this as far as i could tell i think he
had no interest he he
he just he just moved on to something
else maybe he wrote one or two more but
it wasn't
i looked them up the other day i
couldn't find anymore
but you you pioneered my research
and then from there
as i came to the end of my phd i thought
well what what i'd like to do a postdoc
and i wrote to him um and i said would
they if i can get a fellowship could i
come
to austin texas where you are and join
your group
and to my amazement you're up i said
yeah sure i was very short
yeah sure come along
less than two and a half percent it was
less than two and a half pages
so i went to the for what known as the
scrc interviews it's what would now
you'd think of as stfc but at the time
science and engineering research council
and i got the fellowship
and i was all geared up to go
and the pound completely crashed
the pound went from something like 1.70
down to a dollar
and i was being paid in pounds
and so my
my whole fellowship was worth about 10
000 pounds i made inquiries it would
have cost me 10 000 pounds just to rent
a property
and so i was lucky i got so instead of
working with um weinberg
i ended up working with kibble because
imperial also offered me a position and
i took the fellowship to imperial where
i ended up working with some people so
it was fine i mean i
i did i did
i did okay in the end thanks to
thanks to uh imperial but i was gonna go
to i i did i did tell weinberg this i
told him i i met him
um weinberg had a lot of respect for
kibble
and and when tom kibble who you might
remember didn't get the nobel prize
with a video
imperial invited weinberg to give the
main talk at its birth 80th birthday
celebration for tom kibble and weinberg
came in and he gave this staggering talk
no notes no nothing just stood there for
an hour and afterwards we went for
dinner and um
so i told him that story and you know
after he'd cry after he'd stop crying he
was okay about it
he could have worked
and what was he like to talk to was he
know he was it was great it was quite
direct
you know it
didn't
it there were so many people wanting to
just say hello to him it was but he was
very polite and
what do you mean by director then well
he just said um sorry to hear that
then we moved on
it was you know there was
not much
small chat in between now
we people talk about for example the
theory of everything well i suppose you
could argue that that maxwell's bringing
together electricity and magnetism was
the first step on that and the second
step was weinberg bringing
electromagnetism and the weak force
together to make electro weak theory so
you now got building up these ideas to
sort of bring all of physics together
into a theory of everything which is not
completed yet hopefully i think
something like string theory probably a
good candidate for for achieving that
but
it's kind of you see what what what what
weinberg was starting to build there
really the passage towards the theory of
everything i would say
what should we think about
these people dying i mean obviously
people get old and they die yeah but
like what does it mean that some of
these you know a lot of these really big
names in physics are dying now is that
just like does that mean anything or i
think there i think it's a sign that
there's a whole generation of
real superstars
and
it's an interesting question is that
have we got
you know
people to replace them i don't think we
have at the moment i mean we've got some
brilliant people
but they're not
there's one or two i mean there's a
there's the wittons and maybe maldocinas
out there who have had a fantastic
impact
but it's certainly the case that you
know the likes of feynman and gel man
and hawking with hawking evaporation and
and and weinberg you know with his model
of the leptons
they were making predictions for things
that you can go looking for of course
hawking of operations very no one's seen
that but
the idea of you know singularity
theorems of penrose and company um
i'm not sure we we we have that at the
moment right the theoretical position
we're in it's
it's got much more difficult in many
ways the calculations that can be done
have been done
and and we're left with things trying to
figure out where to go from there i
think the subjects in quite an
interesting stage of you know where do
we go from
here and that's one of the big debates
that's going on should there be a new
super collider right to to go looking
for the higgs or go looking for super
symmetry the things that have been put
forward
we don't know what the dark matter is we
don't know what the dark energy is we
don't know where the supersymmetry is
out there we still don't understand why
the particles have the masses that
they've got
and we don't have any
decent explanation for these so i don't
think we could say we have the people
who have made those
fundamental predictions like i would say
weinberg did and feynman did
are you jealous of people like stephen
weinberg it's the point being jealous
it's like they're jealous and messy
you know you just
they're just they're just there right
they're just they're just better right
you know he's blessed and he's brilliant
and you know
i'm just glad that the world of physics
has people like that because they help
us advance so much and also and i think
for those of us that sort of working
you know these levels below
you know they do give us these nuggets
of ideas that we can play with okay
we're never going to do the wonderful
things that
they did but but they give us these
nuggets of ideas and they help us
understand at least um so yeah no the
wirings of the world are wonderful
back in 1973.
so this is a big this is this is a piece
of history is it it really is a piece of
history this this the experiment that
went on in this machine
actually won uh glashoff weinberg and
salam the nobel prize in 1979 what
happened in here they've got a lot to
thank thank this machine for